when we start to think about something
like bitcoin one of the big questions is
uh you can look at what i'll call micro
bitcoin data is on-chain metrics kind of
market structure all the supply demand
mechanisms but it's got this macro
backdrop to it uh i think i've asked you
before but given the current situation
are you more uh putting more weight on
the macro kind of environment or on the
micro market structure of an asset like
bitcoin if you are evaluating bitcoin
and what could happen in the future
yeah no i think i think investors would
do well to do both and this is this is
sort of the issue um and this is we're
all human right we only have 24 hours in
the day and so we're all going to
specialize in whatever is either easiest
or been taught to us throughout our
careers you know but the reality is if
you want to be a great investor i think
you need to do both you need to
understand the bottom-up fundamentals of
the particular assets and asset classes
that you're allocating capital to but
you also need to understand where you
are in the broader cycle um there's sort
of three cycles that we've really
specialized in in terms of measuring
mapping predicting with precise
precision uh at 42 macro and that's the
growth cycle you know where are you in
the growth cycle it's it's a it's a sign
curve you know either accelerating or
decelerating you're at the lows or the
highs where are you inflation cycle same
dynamics and then where are you in the
liquidity cycle which is the most
important cycle as it relates to getting
financial markets right you need to have
a very clear view on where we're headed
from a growth and inflation standpoint
in order to anticipate inflections in
the liquidity cycle so um i think if you
have a good handle on that or you
outsource the risk management of it all
to people like me or you know someone
who does what i do even better than i do
then i think you can really reallocate
your time and focus on the bottom micro
fundamentals but i think i suspect the
problem with a lot of investors watching
the problem with a lot of investors who
came into this week and are having a bad
week is that they spent entirely too
much time focusing on the the bottom-up
fundamentals and not nearly enough time
either focusing on or allocating um to
resources like myself
and so when you look at something like
uh bitcoin let's go to the micro factors
uh obviously there's been a ton of talk
about uh realized price for kind of the
on-chain cost basis i think last week
you had told us that anywhere around
that like 28 000 range you'd get start
getting excited uh we obviously breached
28 000 got down to you know somewhere in
that 25 000 range realize price seems to
be around 24 000 how are you thinking
about these and full well understanding
like now we're talking about micro
improvements of uh you know various
prices of a couple thousand dollars but
but how do you think about where we are
and some of the price action that's
occurred uh given the models you guys
have
yeah so i would actually say it's quite
encouraging that we held so um if you
look at the uh fibonacci retracement
analysis that i put out on twitter
yesterday um relative to uh the to the
entire bull run from the lows that you
and palina were talking about just prior
to my coming on to the highs that we uh
observed uh last fall you know the 61.8
retracement level which has been a you
know a very sort of um sound level to
kind of invest in speculating bitcoin in
throughout the throughout its life cycle
you know that level's at 28 774 and so
we kind of breached below that and now
we're trading right back above it so
it's clear that other investors are
keying off that level and saying hey
this is a good price to buy now the re
and so i do believe that is still a
reasonable price to buy the problem with
we're buying it today is that we're not
yet near that sort of inflection point
in the liquidity cycle we're still in a
very adverse spot in the liquidity cycle
so you know you never want to use pure
technical analysis pure quantitative
analysis that's what we specialize in uh
42 macro you never want to just isolate
one variable when you're making asset
allocation decisions you have to marry
you know obviously the technical
analysis you have to mirrors are out
with the where we are in liquidity cycle
if we got to 28 000 let's call it four
five six months from now and think we're
closer to a federal reserve policy pivot
then i think you buy it would back up
the trunk of both hands now the reason i
sound cautious and concerned right now
um
irrespective of the fact that the level
held is the fact that hey the next line
of support in this fibonacci analysis is
not until we get to 19 270 73 like so if
28 000 doesn't hold over the next few
weeks and couple of months then it's
probably a very quick wash down to 19
000 that's going to cause a lot of
problems obviously in the stable coin
community et cetera so i'm not saying
that will occur but the probability of
that occurring is still very elevated
relative to where we are in the
liquidity cycle and so i think won't
ever want to be uh considered aware of
that risk yeah i i think that's a great
way to kind of look at it talk to us a
little bit more not just maybe in this
situation but in general uh you
obviously have a model you have kind of
hey look this could happen uh if this
doesn't happen then you know this other
thing could happen etcetera how do you
think about uh kind of entering into
markets so for a while now a couple of
weeks you've been talking about raising
cash right and being able to uh kind of
withstand the drawdown in prices of
assets uh and obviously those assets
have drawn down if people had raised
cash and it's a big if but if they had
how do you think about
the best investors in the world starting
to redeploy their capital is it a i'm
gonna try to time the bottom in one shot
do they dollar cost average do they just
wait for confirmation and then go back
on the way up like how does that play
out with many of the clients that you
talk to on a daily basis yeah so just in
general so i i spent my career in the
institutional uh finance community it
you know hedge funds mutual funds etc
and so the the number one thing you you
they do there's a few things they do
that's very different than how the
average retail investor invested i'd say
with respect to the question you asked
it's never making all or nothing
investment decisions you don't want to
go from being max bullish to max bearish
or very bullish to very bearish in one
day or in one series of trades what you
want to be doing is making incremental
bets based on the incremental changes in
the data and the incremental changes in
the probabilistic path forward for the
growth cycle the inflation cycle and the
liquidity cycle and so at some point you
know in the next several months or a
couple of quarters who knows you know
well we have a reasonable view we have
an expectation
in terms of when we're likely to see
some of these changes but the reality is
you want to start to incrementally
allocate get incrementally more bullish
to extent you have raised cash and
you're not panicking on a week like this
week and we certainly given plenty of
warnings for investors to raise cash
because what raising cash does is it
allows you to one sleep soundly at night
on weeks like this week or days you know
like what we've observed in the last 24
to 48 hours but most importantly it
allows you to start taking bites on that
i tweeted out this morning in our macro
minute program and thanks to everybody
who tunes into that
you want to it's not just about dollar
cost averaging particularly when you're
an adverse spot in the cycle you want to
be thoughtful about the size of your dca
purchases you want to be thoughtful
about the frequency of your dca
purchases and so as someone who's
committed to dollar cost averaging
bitcoin you know if you heard me talk
about this you know three four five
months ago you could have slowed down
those purchases reduced the size of
those purchases and now you have even
more capital sitting in your war chest
to actually make better purchases and
speed that up when we get closer to a
pivot and liquidity cycle and that's
what i mean by dynamic dollar cost
averaging got it and so when you see um
kind of this happening uh and people
start to go back into the market is
there uh some sort of um
uh confirmation that uh they end up
looking at or some sort of risk
management so a great example would be
hey i'm gonna start dollar cost
averaging now oh wait the asset
continues to fall and if it falls
certain percent i'm actually gonna get
out of the market like how short term
are these decisions and how much are
people waiting for those confirmations
versus they just take a really really
time horizon like hey man i love the
asset at you know 60 000
at 28 000 it sounds cool if it goes to
25 that sounds even better and if it
goes to you know 19 then i'ma buy as
much as i can like how i guess
sophisticated and and kind of uh minute
detail are people looking at versus
there is some intuition i think it's
overlaid here
yeah so i think there's a combination of
intuition and also what you can afford
to stomach as an investor um and so i
think with respect to something like
dollar cost averaging specifically like
that is a that to me is a personal
choice like how much money are you
willing to risk and lose and at what
speed or what frequency to ride out a
bear cycle like what we're currently
experiencing um you know i think you
know just just just as a function of
process you never want to be looking for
confirmation from markets and the reason
i say that is that markets very seldomly
give you a very clear indication of
what's happening in fact all the best
trades that i've ever seen in my career
either personally or i've seen other
investors make and put on and discuss
with them
in institutional meetings it's usually
when things are not very clear you know
if you if something's clear when you put
the trade on that means the trade has
already probably worked and it's already
probably very crowded so um don't expect
some point in the next three to six
months to get some sort of all clear
signal that it's okay to go buy a bunch
of bitcoin it doesn't work like that
what you're gonna get is incremental
evidence from the economic statistics
that get reported that say hey we're
getting closer to a pivot in the
liquidity cycle what you're going to get
is incremental evidence from the change
in valuations across asset markets to
say hey we're getting closer to levels
that might trigger other investors to
start buying and going back to that
financial conditions chart i don't think
we're at those levels where evaluation
is broadly supportive to make have
people everyone you know including the
largest asset managers in the world hold
their nose and start buying
if you in fact if you look at the flows
data a lot of them are just now starting
to sell in terms of um you know kind of
exiting the equity market et cetera so
again you're not going to get an all
clear signal but what you are going to
get is a lot of information along the
way that can tell you to dial up or dial
down the amount of risk you're taking
and how fast you're taking that risk and
that's exactly what we specialize in
helping investors with